everyone is laughing at me but I I think
she's kind of a badass in terms of style
she likes to party she likes to get down
she likes to stick her tongue out ah
she's like the Michael Jordan of girl
she brings it every time she gets on
camera she does something weird
[Music]
it's my show she did some cities feel
like a Disney Princess she was a kid and
now she's picked up the superstar what's
going on now student by day rock and
roll star by night this is the first
time in my life I've ever been couture
it's creative I think my balls are
showing right now I feel like a very
sexy abominable snowman the pasties
don't leave much to the imagination I
want to go to the gym one day dressed
like this and just hit like a deep squat
set I feel oddly beautiful there's a lot
of skin showing how do you go anywhere a
dress like this
[Music]
I would feel it out there this is the
one where she like invented sticking
your tongue out sideways sorry I feel
like I got kicked out of Chuckie Cheese
I like how the ears were kind of like
nipple flaps like I don't know why they
suddenly labeled what she did it's
working because people have been doing
that forever yeah I was doing that when
I was a teenage boy and I just called it
[Music]
[Applause]
I feel like she's almost like our
generations Madonna right
she loves to shock she loves to outrage
with kind of these clothing statements
these fashion statements these
in-your-face fashion moves I think she
is a very brilliant salesperson of her
own brand if there's one thing she is
its brave I totally get it
I totally get what Miley Cyrus's trying
to do she's trying to be original she's
trying to stand out and it works
she had this image of like the the good
girl preteen star and she like said that
and didn't care what was gonna happen
and it wound up being a big success for
her so I think it is a bold move and as
a cool move